e
[Musique]
nous apprenons qu'un grave accident de
la circulation a eu lieu cet après-midi
dans l'essonne un jeune mécanicien de 32
ans jean-louis brozek qui effectué un
essai sur la moto qu'il venait de
réparer s'est écrasé contre un camion
il a été transporté dans le coma à
l'hôpital de corbeil voyons alfa beta au
plus de réactions est à peine sensible
delta même pas un quart de cycle
[Musique]
le coeur fonctionne encore ouais quand
on l'aide de toute façon plier les
tuyaux nous apprenons qu'un grave
accident de la circulation a eu lieu cet
après midi on laisse comme un jeune
mécanicien de 32 ans jean vibrer et
effectuer un essai sur les moutons qui
vient de réparer s'est écrasé contre un
camion
il est transporté dans le coma à
l'hôpital de copé
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on s'amusait
[Musique]
bah dis donc ça va pas dû tomber loin
tiens tu ferais mieux de les fermer la
fenêtre à côté
[Musique]
ça alors parce qu'il ya le ciel est
plein des toiles
[Musique]
oh merde dit dont ils respirent tout
seuls
aussi le cerveau était mort complètement
foutue embauches immédiates in the wind
de radis d'affaires gang à hackney reina
automatismes dit hors cac bic en poudre
et d'adhésifs pan am rheinfall sh faire
faillite too big to fail mal sauf les
betteraves à âmes vase
ils disent aussi devenu évident que pour
ce métal bislang né à clermont est un
phénomène tout semble être encore plus
basse la double vie de rennes 2 et bac
pro l'allemagne fut que du bonheur je
tombe je vais très vite et nous valent
que deuxième place mondiale il est
invaincu petits veinards t'es pas un
obstacle au fond c'est la manière de
battre a dit et tu sais ce que c'était
ah la vache une souris aux plus petits
une souris qui s'était glissé dans le
pot d'échappement est pas vrai charlot
donc toujours faut le voir pour le
croire ce que tu dis pas que tu avais
déjà démonté tout le moteur et nettoie
ma place
ça faisait pas de l'allumage ça venait
pas des bougies vous voyez pas tout le
merdier
enfin c'est un monde tout de même votre
meilleur copain failli crever c'est un
miracle qu'il soit là et tout ce que
vous trouvez à lui raconter cette
histoire de souris dans un pot
d'échappement beurre ces histoires de
boulot ça t'intéresse un jeu pourri que
ça t'intéresse un ta soeur oui ma soeur
ma soeur c'est toi ma soeur et je te
jure qu'il y'a pas toi pas lavez-vous
deux là et on sera coupée des gosses
hôpital silence c'est écrit dans le code
paris
et comme toute vapeur mais vers 18hoo la
négraille smartphone filles beaucoup en
amérique de sud ptt khemiri femme forte
du marketing de l'islam dans des
chaussons gustin de kamengrad ali s'est
découvert des phonèmes soir lionel non
senna parisse
nous faisons
je voudrais tu en as far hills
las
van den sa forte hausse du cac certaines
personnes à santa monica
la citation
comme toute fille d'auguste balisés
[Rires]
c'est bien mais ce moment-là bergen lot
dit pas qu'on va leur voix les mêmes qui
sont en augmentation dans les charges et
le mec il arrive sur le terrain ce matin
ils voient l'écart entre bourg et les
chars avec la luzerne
il salue et vous voyez plus les charges
des nazis gros comme ça qu'est ce que
vous regrettez
il fait beau mais la 9e j'ai failli
fermer l'année pour communiquer il dit
pour nourrir les chenilles ou non est ce
que je voulais te dire jean louis son
taux qui était qu' on était tous
contents de revoir par me voilà à la
diète
eh ben on ne drague pas d'amis collègues
et patrons concept a3 pas tous les jours
notre enquête on serait adaptée vous
êtes marrants déjà petit soit là ou non
mais des histoires là mon retour contre
les rebelles est bon parce que c'est toi
pass 3 jours
on n'oublie pas mais si je dis tu as
déjà la maison d'habitude enfin comment
comme avant
deux matchs étaient libres
ah bon
[Musique]
m
sur le rallye
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
on nous emmène à thématiser le miel
jean-louis bronzer
[Musique]
voilà
avec une machine de ce genre qu'il sait
enfin que je me suis tué et vous d'après
ce que j'ai cru comprendre je suis morte
dans un accident de cheval
vous connaissez oui une espèce qui leur
servait de monture avant qu'ils
n'inventent ces machines
[Musique]
ah oui pardon parce qu'en plus qu'en
excusez moi depuis quelques jours je
m'étais déjà habitués à utiliser la
parole ou feriez mieux de continuer
comment ça vous êtes spécialiste des
affaires terrestres n'est ce pas alors
vous devriez savoir que les terriens
sont peut être capable de capter nos
zones télépathique nos études sur ce
point nous permettent en aucune façon de
nous prononcer les services de sécurité
estiment eux que nous devons nous
abstenir d'utiliser ce moyen de
communication
sauf en cas d'extrême urgence les
services de sécurité m'ont parfois d'un
peu de souplesse
j'en fais partie de l'oublié pas du
reste c'est un ordre
je sais qu'ils médiatement s'était mis
sur fond
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ici que gbt
qui faites-vous bachata de la moto pour
éviter qu'on l'a vol cela se fait sur
cette planète paraît-il je vous trouve
bien 5 dans vos certitudes pour un
spécialiste méconnaissance de la vie
terrestre je les ai acquises dans nos
universités à plusieurs années lumière
d'ici et croyez-moi entre la théorie et
la pratique il y à un monde
vous menez
je dois d'abord m'assurer que notre
satellite veuille bien sûr nous y a pas
à quoi tranquille par ici
barbe à venir
[Musique]
tenez-moi ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça
un émetteur à ondes directionnelles non
dispersive indétectable j'ai ordre
d'entrer en contact toutes les 24 heures
tenez asseyons-nous labarthe pour
attendre la nuit
il serait temps que vous mettiez au
courant de tout maintenant alors il y as
combien de temps que cette première
expédition des nôtres a été envoyé sur
terre la notion du temps n'est pas la
même ici que sur l' empire des quatre
planètes
c'est à dire un laps de temps assez bref
chez nous correspond à une période
beaucoup plus longue sur quel rapport à
6 à peu près je n'aime pas votre absence
de précision à 5,937 exactement bien
notre expédition est donc installée ici
depuis plus longtemps qu'il n'y paraît
vu de la terre
exact cinq ans terrestres environ quatre
ans neuf mois et dix jours
que tous en train de faire à vrai dire
j'en sais rien apparemment un réflexe
hérité de ce corps
je vous écoute l'expédition comprenait
six membres comprenaient il nous voulons
pas dit avant de vous envoyer à non ce
n'est pas moi qui devais partir ça a été
un changement subit d'affectation il y
avait encore disponibles il fallait
faire vite
alors cette expédition à spa rue qu'est
ce que vous dites disparu au début ils
ont envoyé quelques communiqués puis
soudain plus rien le silence un silence
qui dure depuis malgré tout mes appels
et rien ne laissait prévoir
vous avez des images
oui bien sûr donnez moi la main les
voilà tous les six sous leur aspect de
visiteurs terrestre désincarnation comme
nous non le procédé n'était pas encore
au point l'époque il s'agit du manot id
synthétique en biologie simulé peut-on
envisager une défaillance des
communications dès mon arrivée j'ai
envoyé une série d'appels télépathique
je n'ai reçu aucune réponse défectuosité
dans le fonctionnement de leurs cordes
humanoïdes
nous avons procédé à de nombreux essais
la mise au point était parfaite
les humains alors naturellement c'est ce
que nous craignons si vous voulez j'ai
le rapport du dernier briefing à bord du
satellite avant débarquement l'entrée
hb - 30 attention attention procédure
des débarquements d'engager impact au
point de ralliement à derniers essais de
matériel biologique un vote sarko
coefficient 18 sexe mâle assimilation
langage en bonne voie bon fonctionnement
organique aussitôt contact commencerait
enregistrement images circuits 7 et 9
terminée
voua lambda
coefficient 17 sexe mâle aucun problème
mécanique
légère tendance à la stabilité thermique
terminée avoue thierry
coordonnée par fait coefficient 19 sec
smarl assimilation optimale prêt à
rejoindre des atterrissages régions
équatoriales terminée
avoue-t-il
[Applaudissements]
irin
coefficient 18 sexe mâle aucune
altération des facultés mentales test
gamme à epsilon positif epsilon positive
epsilon pas
excusez incident mineur sur circuit
langage fait révision circuit ses 12e 16
avant l'atterrissage à vous-même nos
coefficient 18,5 sa malle grande
souplesse des mouvements terminé à
voudrait qu'à terrifiant 19 sexe mâle
capacité d'habileté manuelle entièrement
contrôlée su près des atterrissages a
assuré réalisations plastiques terminée
h 27
priorité respecter strictement les
consignes de sécurité est passée
inaperçue ce que disent ou font elle
demande un autre mental à ew sur
fréquence à 0 4 et 0 c'est terminé
dites-moi sexe mâle qu'est ce que ça
veut dire exactement rien détails sans
importance je vous expliquerai plus tard
le débarquement s'est opéré normalement
oui les premiers rapports nous ont été
régulièrement transmis à l'institut des
affaires terrestres
ce n'est qu'après six mois je parle en
tant terrestre que les rapports ont
cessé tous en même temps à peu près le
dernier a été envoyé par sarko fait voir
[Applaudissements]
je me trouve ici dans la cité paris
capitale du pays france
[Applaudissements]
depuis une semaine
j'enregistre ici les images nécessaires
à l'étude sociologique dalanda
la société humaine est de plus en plus
déroutante à mesure qu'on l'étudié il
faudra des années avant d'en comprendre
le fonctionnement
[Applaudissements]
les contradictions de ce monde ne seront
peut-être pas résolument aussi nul que
tu peux faire
[Applaudissements]
tél renate et que ce qui m'arrive rien
de grave il faudra vous y habituez votre
corps a besoin de repos
quelle étrange mécanique n'est ce pas
oui
vous rendez vous compte que nous sommes
les premiers à habiter ainsi de
véritables corps humains
peut-être ne savons n'aurait pas disparu
s'il avait pu bénéficier de cette
technique continu ou voulez vous
un des éléments aussi négatif
moi
je veux dire par là
que les deux poules de ces
contradictions matérialisme et
spiritualisme semble se compléter plutôt
que se détruire
allende d'art est parti hier pour
poursuivre son enquête dans un pays
voisin
[Applaudissements]
inutile d'insister il faut aller dormir
quelle perte de temps si tu piques il
faudra vous habituer
cela fait partie désormais de nouvelles
réalités biologiques
[Musique]
le voilà les salles de notre espèce les
seuls oui nos compagnons nous les
retrouvons
ce
payant
excuse moi je savais pas
[Musique]
je suis désolé te déranger mais ces gens
l'okimo voir on a besoin de toi
l'atelier parce que y'a un beckham
d'albert est alors dès lors il veut
absolument que ce soit toi qui habite au
coin il a bien dit lui et personne
d'autre
alors j'arrive dans 20 minutes pas vu
non ça va pas durer
yann berck et un atelier il a par ses
affaires de sa journée dit la patte
ouverte à mon client
pierre di in the garden koffi il faut
que j'aille à l'atelier lui c'est même
ce rendez vous à midi et ça au petit
square ou de la rue en fin de l'atelier
avec moi
thür a rien
castle
avant de voir cela n'ait jamais vu aucun
bruce a
[Musique]
raté mais c'est vous jean louis je vous
ai pourtant interdit de correspondants
télépathie
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
oui
vous arrive nous avons été découverts et
savent qui nous sommes
qui ça eh bien les humains expliquez moi
tout à l'heure à querrien m'a abordée
donnez moi plutôt votre poignet j'ai
gagné mme mazel tov
je m'étais fait à paris avec puff daddy
qu'est ce que vous voulez passer ma vie
à des coûts et puis pour commencer un
petit temps de voiture ça vous plairait
pas au passé mais pour nous sauver des
dangers qui nous environne c'est pas un
quartier pour nous ça vient quand vous
regardez parmi ces ploucs
on dirait une déesse trouvé ni ciel
aller voter
[Applaudissements]
ce portugais
qu'en pensez vous je crois que vous êtes
méprise sur ses intentions
rappelé hier sexe mâle j'avais promis de
vous expliquer bon et bien voilà la
biologie et la génétique sur la terre
sont très différentes de celles de l'an
pire des quatre planètes
chez nous la reproduction s'effectuant
par scissiparité les sexes n'existe pas
terre au contraire la reproduction de
l'espèce nécessite l'union d'un élément
mal et d'un élément fait
excusez moi mais je ne vois pas le
rapport avec mon histoire
attendez vous allez voir l'existence de
deux sexes sur cette planète créé des
rapports de relation très complexe entre
les représentants des deux sexes l'homme
et la femme
le premier cherchant à séduire la
seconde pour s'unir avec or il se trouve
que le hasard vous a attribué un corps
de femme et de très jolies femmes donc
d'autant plus recherchée par les mâles
c'est à dire les hommes c'est une main
avec sa voiture était en mal
vous voulez dire que ce mal me
recherchait pour s'unir avec moi en vue
de se reproduire
oui enfin quelque chose comme ça étrange
espèce décidément que c'était rien mais
au fait vous êtes un hâle vous aussi oui
mais notre cas est un peu spécial bon
ben je crois qu'il est temps que nous
avions des jeunes que nous allions quoi
déjeuner mangez vous ne sentez pas une
sensation de vide par ici si
effectivement vous voyez et comment
allons nous faire
rassurez vous il y à des endroits prévus
pour cela des restaurants à ces danses
là bas ma mère madame matisse
m'a donné une carte avec une adresse
voilà bah très bien allons-y
aux taxis
[Musique]
allez venez
des fraises et pour commencer
oui bien monsieur est ensuite sardines
fraîches grillé et poulet aux écrevisses
madame aussi oui
et comme boisson brut impérial 72 une
bouteille pour moi aussi futile une
bouteille pour moi aussi de bouteilles
brut impérial 72
[Musique]
je
il fallait les voir à l'établi sur ce
moteur un système archaïque dont j'avais
du reste aucune idée elle travailler
tout seul sans que j'avais commandé
voilà elle savait ce que j'avais à faire
il m'arrive d'avoir peur d'elle parfois
à vous pardon je vous demande si vous
arrive d'avoir peur de vos mains
non on va là unités c'est amusant comme
service non vous avez remarqué plus on
voit prendra
[Musique]
jean-louis mais j'ai une question à vous
poser
soyez from m'avez vous appelez un
télépathie ce matin non alors qui ça
peut être quelqu'un vous a appelés et le
contact est rompu presqu'aussi tout mais
c'est grave ce que vous êtes là qu'est
ce que vous avez
je sais pas je me sens bien
pas vous léger
[Musique]
s'il savait que nous sommes vraiment il
en ferait des pets
question leur disais pas question
n'oubliez pas que notre mission est
secret jean-louis mais qu'est ce qui
nous arrive j'ai pas mais je crois qu'il
vaut mieux partir c'est ça partout non
attendez quad ou s'il vous plaît il faut
payer pour manger que drôle de planète
[Musique]
allons les amoureux n'hésitez pas à le
spectacle formidable
la séance commence à l'instant avec deux
places pour les siens
[Musique]
et
regardez c'est la reproduction exacte de
notre cosmodrome centrale sarko ne leur
a rien caché
tout y est à part c'est ridicule petit
personnage faire sarko nous avons besoin
de toi
ailleurs aussi on a besoin de moi
poursuivez votre retard
je reviendrai
[Musique]
mes compliments ils font du bon travail
vous savez je connais sarko je comprends
pas comment il a pu accepter de ses amis
anciens spectacles et surtout de trahir
les secrets de notre civilisation
qu'allons-nous faire maintenant d'abord
le retrouver ça ne doit pas être bien
difficile
j'ai noté le nom du metteur en scène un
certain il faut lecture ont procuré aux
femmes 63e
es et tu entends fait cesser
d'importuner cénomes l'étranger
zarko que signifie cette mascarade
soyez les bienvenus sur l' empire des
quatre planètes acier d'insolence darko
pourquoi avez-vous cessé de communiquer
avec le satellite
bravo bien joué et 15 pour vous vous
êtes journaliste zarko il va falloir
vous expliquer volontiers mais si vous
permettez ce truc petits pains chauds
je leur mettrais pour les photos voilà
je suis à vous qu'est ce que vous
désirez savoir eh bien je vous écoute
vous travaillez pour quel journal nous
voudrions parler à hippolyte durant il
publie deux ans
est ce que vous seriez les seuls sur la
terre à ignorer qu'il a une sainte
horreur des journalistes mais d'où
sortez vous tous les deux à l'emea me
raccompagner les visiteurs jusqu'au
marché de l' empire et qu'on n'entende
plus jamais parler d'eux
[Applaudissements]
alors impossible d'obtenir son adresse
la vie privée d'hippolyte durand est une
véritable forteresse
il est pourtant celle à pouvoir nous
renseigner quoi qu'il en soit la
conduite de votre ami zarco est
inqualifiable
je ne comprends pas ce qui a pu le
pousser à se confier à un terrible
c'est zarko il souffre il a besoin de
nous une image suggéré de telles forces
la source ne peut pas être bien loin
trenet moi la main qu'est ce que c'est
que ça regardez cet oiseau pour lui le
temps s'est arrêté
comme pour toute vie autour de nous
si je n'avais pas pris votre main le
temps se serait arrêté également pour
vous venez mais pourquoi avez-vous fait
sa lettre qui nous a suggéré l'image de
sarko est certainement caché quelque
part non loin de nous venez nous allons
fouiller les environs
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez dire que le temps ait
réellement arrêté pour tout le monde
exactement et personne ne se rendra
compte qu'il a été interrompue le temps
reprendra à l'instant précis où il avait
ceux ci
qui êtes vous
poc je m'appelle puck vous savez où est
sarko n'est ce pas je vous préviens que
je ne vous lâcheront pas avant que vous
nous ayez dit où il était je ne suis
qu'un modeste farfadets sens important
va ce geste est grave il faut que j'en
réfère aux espèces supérieurs
qu'appelle-t-on vers la capelle tonton
berlin
et
nos deux amis sont près de moi réclame
sarko tenez il veut vous parler
ça y est je crois qu'il récupère pas les
yeux eh bien non c'est nous tu me de
ventes et nous a refait le brave peur
non ça va mieux ben ouais ça va mieux
regarder la lui reviennent merci tient
bon à coup ça tu as bien qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ça serait plutôt à toi nous
le dire et je voyais du chantier à côté
qui vous ont ramassé dans les pommes
vous avez été attaqués ou quoi je me
rappelle plus très bien à laisser leur
point de ses esprits bon c'est bon ça va
derrière
[Musique]
extrait à ce tout nouveau ça vaille les
moyens robin d'ailleurs tu es vie privée
ne me regarde d'autres ports
contenant la mort
c'est ici
sarko sarko
zarko
fort car score
à sa mort
il est mort il faut faire disparaître le
corps au plus vite avant que les
terriens le voit et l'examinent de trop
près vous avez un moyen oui
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
je
craig t
[Musique]
et
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rapports enquêtes menées par tolra et
moi-même harguine sur disparition
d'expéditions scientifiques venus de
notre gars comprenait six membres
chargée d'étudier hommes sur planète
terre 6 humanoïdes zarco à la pire vie
qui rit même nom et rida
tall rac et moi même sont incarnés dans
corps humains victimes d'accidents
mortels et rallye mais par nos soins
jean louis il brossait et renate matière
nous sentons entouré ennemi invisible
deux humains suspect un homme est un
réalisateur sinima hippolyte durant
dernière minute venant de découvrir qu'à
d'argon accompagnés d'un avertissement
retourner tous venus
vous
réponse à votre demande le gouvernement
de l'empiré vous devez savoir pendant
qu'un cas et disent prêts à intervenir
dans cette affaire il existe et qui est
l'un et l'autre à vous et à vous simple
de trouver les solutions appropriées aux
problèmes qui peuvent se poser
instructions de vos esprits vous donne
qu'une énorme supériorité sur vos
éventuels adversaires rien et pis quoi
précisément il semble nous veillons à
faire à des adversaires disposant de
voix ya plus élaboré que prévu et et ça
se termine
ces bureaucrates
je voudrais aller voir à notre place ça
précisément ils ne sont jamais à notre
place on m'a dit non non tu te prends
pour une bille ou quoi ce qu'il va
falloir choisir mon petit grain parce
que août et guérillas tu reprends le
boulot
août est toujours dans les vapes et
renvoie à l'hosto non c'est vrai j'en
voyais le toit sa place on a besoin de
toi à l'atelier maintenant surtout en ce
moment il ya un boulot dingue attend que
tu étais malade bon on s'est débrouillés
comme on a pu mais maintenant ça va plus
surtout si c'est pour faire le joli
coeur tu m'as dit quelque chose bon dieu
parle de choses qu'il va pas mais on
dirait que ça va trop bien au contraire
on fait tu te rends compte que ce fou de
toi non échos des mesures de filles des
allumeuses et à l'intérieur ni bhl de
libre la banquise n'a pas besoin de vous
ici retournez dans votre monde
qu'est ce que vous dites écoute colette
de mes potes ça tu veux oui normal et
c'est là je veux savoir ce que vous
voulez dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais pas moi enfin que j'en disais ah
c'était pour poser comme ça sans penser
à un an ça ne peut pas continuer comme
ça non tout ça bob colette charlot
toutes ses relations compliquées nous
étouffer nous paralyse
il faut trouver quelque chose les
spécialistes des affaires terrestres
c'est vous à vous de trouver une
solution
évidemment ces corps humain présente pas
mal d'inconvénients mais mais aussi des
avantages
mettez ça pourquoi je sais pas mais de
rabon
en tout cas demain je peux pas faire
autrement que d'aller à l'atelier
d'accord je me chargerai seul
d'hippolyte durant quoi vous pouvez vous
débrouiller tout seul ne vous inquiétez
pas je connais mon métier
[Musique]
pardon monsieur hippolyte durand ne
tombe pas aujourd'hui rapide sommes nous
arrivés un peu tard
il a réuni studio et honnête ou à
l'extérieur où c'est moussa un pénis on
n'avait jamais réparé merci ça n'a pas
d'importance
merci
il ya de la visite pour vous effectif de
la ville où sont ceux achetés il visait
à melwood l'offensive qui a tué il ya
alain grand de tous bon ben je préfère
vous laisser seuls avec eux je vous ai
tant qu'à faire des vidéos qu'ils sont
avec 110 euros man qui sache
jean-louis brozek
et bien que ce qui s'est passé ces
terriens sont vraiment exténuant il
paraît que ce n'est pas convenable que
j'habite chez vous pourquoi vous avez
une idée c'est à dire que norme sur
moselle tout ce qu'on vous sert comme
lui là c'est beau l'amour et ça qu'est
ce que ça veut dire si vous parlez
plutôt de vos dents fin de ces personnes
que veulent t'ils que je rentre en
allemagne avec eux ils pensent que je
suis malade
ils disent de nîmes fu man ou quelque
chose comme ça
comment se débarrasser de ces gens là et
je sais j'ai à peu près le même problème
d'autant plus qu'il ya du nouveau
hippolyte durant n'est plus ici il est
parti à venise il paraît voilà qui ne
simplifie pas les choses
venise oui
je crois qu'il ya un moyen
et
jean-louis procès acceptez-vous de
prendre pour épouse relaté ursula
elizabeth may pied celle relatée est
aussi là elizabeth may pied serre
acceptez-vous de prendre pour époux
jean-louis procès oui je vous déclare
unis par les liens du mariage et
d'enfants c'est le curé que j'écrase en
bon élève alors il faut prendre ce
palais pour bernard dardenne da
à la sortie des loyers
et amène un euro non non non on vous
embrasse et pendant pour voir sa bonne
heure
m
- à quoi jean louis borloo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous dormez
et dites moi et qu'est ce que vous en
savez de ce pays l'italie
oh pas grand chose juste le début d'une
étude sociologique communiqué part
annoncé avoir versé en général lesquels
alenda
un des lots tous se trouverait donc en
italie vous croyez que le voyage
d'hippolyte durant serait en rapport
avec je ne crois rien je constate
seulement que le passage d'hippolyte
durant à paris coïncide avec la mort de
zarko vous avez raison
il faut prévenir lambda s'il est
toujours là bas mais vous m'avez dit
qu'aucun des nôtres n'a répondu à vous
appelle télépathiques
oui mais ils y reçoivent peut-être nos
ennemis les reçoivent aussi de toute
façon nous et demi je suis sûr qu'ils
savent que nous sommes dans ce train
c'est vrai essayer de prévenir allende
al hamdane alain bernard si vous êtes en
italie prenez garde à vos épaules yves
durand probablement mélina la mort d'un
des nôtres
zarko arrivons à venise demain matin
essayez d'entrer en contact avec nous
dès que possible
répondez à london répondait répondait
[Applaudissements]
devant l'italienne 12 en italien vous
avez quelque chose a déclaré rick perry
oui a déclaré j'avais alcool cigarettes
j'avais des bijoux
[Musique]
qui sont des genêts oui oui la lune de
miel et et le voyage dénoncées oui j'ai
compris vers et ja est toutefois que ce
qu'ils explosent et squeeze et mes
compliments
bienvenue en italie et produits
[Musique]
et
à la barre
regardez les natecia lamda il nous a
entendus
attendez moi avec les valises
[Musique]
madame et monsieur projet
qui êtes vous le chauffeur de retard
gorille elle dit vous avez retenu une
chambre mais nous ne pouvons continuer
aucune chambre dans un hôtel
qu'est ce qu'il veut excusez-moi j'ai
obéi aux ordres on m'a dit de venir vous
chercher
très bien nous allons voir ça
[Musique]
et
je suis un gros sac je sais pas oui
j'ose espérer que vous avez fait bon
voyage
nous nous avons été nous battre ensemble
de 4 ne partant même superbe avec vue
sur le grand canal et on n'a pas trop
maintenant matrimoniale reste avec toute
annonce de felice stationné à quel coût
pour toi de votre mariage qui retenait
la chambre comment vous ne savez pas non
maintenant j'ai eu trop de matières sein
est la maman de madame la région de
l'attique le signera signera ses vous
voulez bien l'esprit
c'est pas très fonctionnel tout ça en
effet il semble que les humains prennent
plaisir à compliquer les choses les plus
élémentaires
et pourtant vous allez trouver ça idiot
il se dégage de tout ceci une sensation
de bien-être préoccupez vous plutôt du
sort d'un lamda à vous avez raison je
suis stupide non pas stupides
superficielles j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
maintes fois de le constater
eh bien comment faire il est d'abord un
poids que j'aimerais éclaircir tout de
suite je suppose que c'est cela qui leur
sert de téléphone oui un instant s'il
vous plaît il polit durant dans le hall
il veut vous parler
hippolyte durant oui allez-y je vous
rejoins tout de suite
monsieur bronzé actes et ça s'il vous
plaît j'aimerais que les faux nez en
allemagne à mme bourque s'il vous plaît
eh bien oui ce monsieur était le
monsieur qui m'attendait il est où
je ne saurais vous dire monsieur je n'ai
pas à marquer je vous ai donné ça au cas
par cas
[Musique]
non
je viens de parler à ma mère au
téléphone elle m'a affirmé qu'elle
n'avait pas joué deux chambres pour nous
ni ici ni ailleurs
regardez l'homme blanc rouge c'est lui
marionnettes
c
que tu
vous croyez qu'il sait qui nous sommes
je n'ai pas l'impression pour tard il
m'a regardé plusieurs fois
oui moi et alors cela prouve que c'est
la femme qui l'intéressent et un
policier de lempire des 80 m et comment
comptez vous entrez en contact
je crois que pour une fois votre qualité
de femme va pouvoir me servir comme on
l'entend défaut décidément il va falloir
que je prenne en main votre éducation
terrestre dès que je vous appelle c'est
tout à l'heure quelque chose s'est passé
en moi qui ne m'était jamais arrivé ah
oui au fait c'est bien vous pensez que
c'est un truc qui utilise avec toutes
les femmes c'est pas possible
vous êtes jeunes mariés oui c'est bien
mon vieux j'ai l'impression que ça
commence très bien oui je peux vous
poser une question
autant de questions que vous vous donnez
vous avez connu sarko n'est ce pas là
tous les mains je les connais c'est lui
qui vous a donné tous ces renseignements
sur l' empire des quatre planètes
non rigolez ou quoi
il faut me dire tout ce que vous savez
de sa mort de sa mort sarko sarko est
mort assassiné
monsieur hippolyte durant dix jours vous
mentez je vous ai vu cet après midi
diriger la mise en scène de votre film
est vraiment je suis son assistant
hippolyte essoufflé il m'a demandé de
faire quelques plans d'ensemble vous
l'avez vu vous il vous a fait prévenir
où peut-on trouver politique durant qui
êtes vous l'adresse d'hippolyte durant
il nous la faut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où avez vous trouvé ce à quoi ton est ce
que vous avez sur vous ça j'ai trouvé ça
dans la salle de bain c'est très
agréable et très frais sur la peau
devriez essayer c'est les femmes qui
portent sa les hommes eux ils mettent
des pyjamas hommes femmes je crois que
je ne m'y habituerai jamais vous vous
êtes pourtant pas mal débrouillé avec le
jeune homme
je n'ai rien fait du tout c'était une
idée avoue renate je voulais vous
demander
lorsque je vous ai embrassé pendant le
repas tenace quand même vous ressenti et
bien c'est curieux comme un léger
effritement de la peau sur tout le corps
oui c'est exactement ce que ça va faire
et pourquoi me demandez-vous cela pour
rien pour rien
voilà c'était plutôt raté notre petite
expédition ce soir je ne trouve pas
j'essaie que je voulais qu'est ce que
c'est l'adresse d'hippolyte durant j'ai
juste eu le temps de lui emprunter avant
l'arrivée de tous ces masques ah bravo
et pourra vous l'avez pas dit il faut
bien se donner un peu entre collègues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les papiers
forcément important oui le petit
déjeuner mais qu'elle aurait dû donc
mais dit déjà oui oui merci jean louis
jean-louis mais qu'est ce que vous
faites sur ce niveau
et bien c'est à dire que je je
n'arrivais pas à dormir à côté de vous
alors j'ai pensé que vous avez pensé
quoi tu serais mieux ici vous savez
l'heure qu'il est non midi or ce sacré
sommeil quelle perte de temps
[Applaudissements]
renate renate qui se passe t-il regardez
qu'est ce qu'ils disent
un mort étrange ils ont découvert un
corps abandonnés s'est tenue dans une
gondole
le médecin qui a fait le premier constat
parle d' anomalie anatomique aberrante
une autopsie officielle doit avoir lieu
cet après midi à l'institut médico légal
il faut empêcher ça à tout prix
[Musique]
signalez prévoit qu'au maintien biscuits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'identique en masse et quand
j'entends un matin en asie après nous
devrions en date a dit à kevin boss
dir
diarra maintenir
[Musique]
abo
donc un abri
marina va quitter la journée
qu'est ce qu'il dit dans tous sont déjà
venus avant lui le corps dalanda a
disparu commence à un enlèvement en
armes et puis ça a connu masqué diamètre
ces gens là c'est hippolyte durand qui
nous donnera l'explication
maintenant nous savons où le trouver
presto alcon pour unis cnt
[Musique]
regardez
gêné il faut monter par là et bien
grimper
dépêchez vous
effeuiller ouvrir aussi tôt ne craignez
rien je vous couvre
la cour dit
si j'étais à mal
monavie tita preuve
regardez
à luanda
c'est un piège
vous avez vu
[Musique]
on est suivi depuis notre arrivée mais
qui ça je ne sais pas qu'il faut partir
maintenant
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
je crois que maintenant on laisse
conclure cash ou sinon les gens nous
verrons apparaître brusquement
des rondeaux que jamais c'est hippolyte
sûrs
ni viole les idéaux que la foule
patty intime et les vols des signaux
vous êtes ridicule que voulez vous que
je fasse deux sens et que signifie ce
sourire
il faut bien s'étonner quelquefois entre
collègues signal pendant un an j'ai tout
dit
merci
roger
pour la première fois que nous sommes
sur terre sans le duo temporisateurs
nous sommes perdus aucune communication
avec notre satellite est maintenant à
nous de jouer
amat et renate vous m'entendez je vous
entend j'en ris mais je vous avais
interdit d'utiliser la télé factice
excusez moi c'est fait sur genre d'une
tour à l'autre bout de la ville
cette ligue alors il faut que vous
veniez me revoir immédiatement pourquoi
vous avez trouvé quelque chose oui un
terrien qui ont aidé à être l'exact de
nos ennemis
un personnage étrange un vieux
brocanteurs il est prêt à nous parler
moyennant finances nous avons rendez
vous dans une demi heure
rené 500 me lire avec vous et venez au
cam qui est mort des labels clean l'abri
de l'ordinaire qui se consolera place
j'arrive aux roms il ne sait pas ce qui
l'attend ne craignez rien si les choses
tournent mal pour lui j'arrêterais le
temps regardez les ans mordu à l'hameçon
[Musique]
et maintenant nous il faut plus les
lâcher
[Musique]
vous avez arrêté le temps non je ne
comprends pas
il est bienvenu
nous nous attendions qui sans nous et
bien tout ceci ce sont des mannequins de
filles il représente toute l'histoire
humaine
nous ne sommes pas venus pour eux mais
pour sarko à lambda et les autres
regardez le bien ça son auteur qui vont
vous juger comme ils l'ont déjà fait
pour vos semblables
ce que vous appelez zarco est un lambda
emparez-vous 2
mais vous oubliez le pickpocket de la
place saint marc voici le véritable
objet celui que vous tenez là n'est
qu'une pâle copie le tribunal de
l'histoire nous change is quant aux
preuves des tartares christophe colomb
découvreur des amériques
alexandre borgia princes de l'église et
pas très chrétien
maximilien robespierre membres du comité
de salut public
catherine la grande arène de toutes les
russies aménophis
pharaon d'égypte mao tsé toung fondateur
de la république populaire de chine
avait été délégué par le genre humain
bonjour j'ai entre un jour et décider du
sort de deux étrangers à la planète
conformément 3 génétique de la
préservation de l'espèce
je déclare ce procès ouvert veuillez
lire l'acte d'accusation les deux rien
dire ici présents sont accusés de s'être
introduits sur notre planète de l'avoir
fait en usurpant de façon criminelle et
profanatrice les dépouilles de deux
corps humain de s'être livrée par
l'intermédiaire de ce corps un simulacre
d'une cérémonie sacré le mariage d'un
homme et d'une femme
et enfin d'avoir mené des activités
d'espionnage à l'encontre de la société
hummer accusés reconnaissez-vous les
faits répond b reconnaissez-vous les
faits les faits soit mais pas
l'interprétation vous obtenez bouyer
décliner votre réelle identité dans leur
langue d'origine
issa damas qu'il est all right comment
savez-vous c'est là c'est nous qui
posons des questions
vous êtes originaire de laon pire des
quatre planètes
nous n'avons rien à vous dire mes chers
enfants les accusations portées contre
vous sont déjà bien assez lourd je vous
en conjure fait prendre moins de bonne
volonté
une collaboration loyale votre part
pourrait vous valoir la vie sauve
[Applaudissements]
j ignorais le pouvoir de la torture
alors pourquoi vous nous proposer de
collaborer quand vous dites parce que
les enfants votre cas est différent à
votre incarnation humaines vous
appartenez quelques pas à notre race et
nous avons su populariser contre vous de
tels procédés nous n'hésiterons pas si
vous persistez je ne suis pas une
créature humaine je ne parlerai pas et
je demande à être traité comme mes
frères
réfléchissez bien vous ignorez ce qu'est
la souffrance humaine
votre corps et votre chair délicate se
révolteront canton à boulleret
contraindront votre esprit que vous le
vouliez ou non vous ne tirerai rien de
moi c'est aussi votre position
naturellement
il va donc être procédé à votre égard à
l'application de la question ordinaire
[Musique]
la question sera appliquée en premier
lieu à celui d'entre vous qui a usurpé
le corps d'une femme
la douleur dans votre chair libère les
paroles de votre esprit
jean-louis 21
[Applaudissements]
non
n'oublie pas n'oublie jamais que vous
devez votre grâce à ce geste que tu
viens d'accomplir pour elle andy lamya
madou et bien commun
et renate je sais bien un diamant reste
en guinée
comment les créer les dongria tu
achèteras s'est immolé comme trop basse
a compté et agoria pour mais face au
mieux ce que les trois poteaux
on sera que dirige le inkling orient
peut il tomber
coc
propre à 6 mai que et au bras si tous
les feux sont au vert
c'est bien là
à
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai pas soumis au
voici désormais seul et sans être sur
cette planète
aucun moyen de communication avec nathan
satellite
jean-louis je voudrais savoir
aj que vous l'avez fait hier pourquoi
voulez-vous parler le savez très bien
quand ils ont voulu me torturer
c'était idiot vous n'aviez aucune chance
je sais je ne sais pas ce qui m'a pris
une impulsion à contrôlable
un héritage de votre corps humain
probable
et si permis périlleux pirelli
tout peut encore être sauvé venez
rejoindre média du mono cylindre retrait
pour preuve il n'a pas dit couleur
rejoigne sa mission consistait à étudier
les tribus primitives de l'afrique
australe doit être sûrement là bas
espérant qu'il ne lampard père et nous
devons d'abord faussé compagnie à ceux
d'ici
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]